pour me détendre et les petits fait quoi
pour se détendre du golfe pour le départ
vous j'ai beaucoup de lectures à la
france c'est le pays des doigts de leur
en dit non la france est le pays le pays
de moi je suis fan 2 je suis fan de
dorothée
ah oui j'ai pas honte de le faire la
seule fois où je me suis fait [ __ ]
sait si dans une sandwicherie jp un
sandwich avait rien dedans
la france de le pen c'est la can neu il
est trop fort avec la navy voit tout
j'ai jamais dit ça à personne mais mes
laurent baffie tient diable qu'un job
chez terrain c'est vrai j'ai été voir
tous ces trucs et acheter les clés de la
bonne elle m'a dit faut pas y aller seul
merci d'avoir respecté la france et ils
sont nombreux
d'où l'importance à nice le comté jour
j'aimerais bien avoir une plus grosse
montre parce que je n'ai pas peur si
elle est du mexique quand tu quand tu
dis moi dis et auxerre magnéto